So, assigning a string to a variable is just
like assigning a number to a variable. We can do
that with an assignment statement. My name is Dave. So,
I'll assign the string Dave, to the name, to the
variable name. The nice thing about using a variable like
this, is now we could have code. Say print Hello
plus name. Here hello is a string. Name is a
variable. If you assigned name to mean some other string,
this will print Hello whatever the value of
name is. I've introduced a new operator here.
We're using the plus operator. We already saw
plus on numbers. Now, we're using plus on strings.
It means something different. What plus means with
strings is concatenation. So we can put strings
together by using the plus operator. The value
of the string plus another string is the concatenation.
That's a new string that's a result of pasting
those two strings together. So let's try that in
the Python interpreter. So here I've initialized the variable
name to be the string Dave, and I'm going to
print out hello plus name. You'll see I won't
get quite what I want from this? Here's what
happens, it concatenated the two strings together, it doesn't
add spaces or anything automatically. So now we've got,
the output is hello Dave, without any space in
it. We need to add a space here. Now
we'll have hello space Dave, which looks more like
we want. We can keep doing this just like we
could use the plus operator with numbers more than
once, we can use it with strings more than once.
Adding another string to the end, now we've got
the exclamation point I need. Maybe one is not enough.
We can keep adding more exclamation points. Now I have a more pleasant reading.